everyone is counting the cost
not least motorists who have been
exposed to high oil prices because of
the war in Ukraine
but are they paying more than necessary
the competition regulator the CMA has
accused supermarkets of increasing their
margins on fuel at a time when
households are feeling the pinch we have
seen evidence that suggests that this
isn't entirely due to factors outside of
retailers control and in particular what
we've seen is some evidence that at
least one retailer has taken an internal
decision to increase their margin
targets and that other retailers have
become aware of that and and may have
adjusted their conduct accordingly in
its investigation the competition
regulator found that Supermarket fuel
margins have increased from under four
people per liter in 2017 to over 10
people per liter in 2022
this is the products of a year-long
investigation that still has some time
to run but the competition regulator
hasn't had an easy time of it it accused
supermarkets of being uncooperative
saying that they were insufficiently
forthcoming with the evidence
so it will now interrogate management
hauling them in for interviews to get to
the bottom of what's going on
the supermarkets say their prices remain
competitive and that they're trying
their best to Shield customers from the
effects of rampant inflation but
campaign groups are skeptical the
biggest retailers have a lot to answer
and that's why there's going to be
interviews with the CMA coming up if you
go to Northern Ireland where the
supermarkets don't have such a big hold
but holds up the price of diesel is far
cheaper and fuel generally is cheaper
than the rest of the UK so if
something's not working properly it's
not just fuel prices that have raised to
eyebrows with food prices jumping at a
rate of almost 20 percent the
competition regulator is also scanning
the aisles for unfair price increases so
far it's found nothing unreasonable but
it's keeping a close eye on the
supermarkets they will not be able to
get away with using inflation as an
excuse for profiteering
gabri nawan Sky News